[P. Norvig] So, Dave, I hear you just finished a great class, CS101: Introduction to Computer Programming
[D. Evans] Thanks, Peter, it's been a lot of fun,
and I heard you're going to be teaching a new class that starts soon.
[P. Norvig] That's right; I'm starting up with 212, Design of Computer Programs
It's all about the process of design;
how you go from an informal description of a problem
to working code...uh...through a process of decomposition
and how to distinguish a good design from maybe a not-so-good design.
[D. Evans] Cool; that sounds really useful what...what students should be learning
after 101.  What's the first unit about?
[P.Norvig] Well, first unit is actually about ranking hands in a game of poker.
[D. Evans] Ahhh...I think I probably should learn that.
[P. Norvig] Hmm...well, let's play.  [D. Evans] Ok.
Well, I'm going to bet...101...
[P. Norvig] Hmm...
[D. Evans] ...billion nanodollars.
[P. Norvig] I'll see your 101, and I'll raise you...212.
[D. Evans] Wow...hmm...well, I'm going to go all in.  And I also want the shirt off your back.
[P. Norvig] The shirt off my back.  Well, I'm pretty confident, so I'm all in, too.  What do you got?
[D. Evans] I got three kings and two jacks.
[P. Norvig] Ahhh... full house.  Well, I got four aces, and we'll soon see
how to program a computer to know that four aces beats a full house.
[D. Evans] It's good you didn't want my shirt then.
[P. Norvig] Ok, we'll see you in class.
[CS212: The Design of Computer Programs]
[Taught by Professor Peter Norvig]